c'est l'heure de l'invité politique du
matin je vous lisais ce matin Marc féno
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire avec Alex
bouyaguet pas seulement d'ailleurs
du modèle on va parler notamment
beaucoup de la réforme des retraites et
aussi rentrer dans les retraites des
agriculteurs puisque c'est son
portefeuille politique du matin Marcelo
Marc bonjour
Elisabeth borne bataille en ce moment
beaucoup pour obtenir une majorité sur
la réforme des retraites
que dit François Bayrou il dit que le
référendum aurait été éventuellement le
meilleur moyen pour faire passer cette
réforme c'est pas un drôle de moment
pour dire ça il a pas dit ça précisément
parce que j'étais assez hier donc il a
dit que le référendum est pour lui un
moyen de temps en temps de trancher un
certain nombre de questions il a dit il
a dit par ailleurs que sur la question
des réformes de retraite il était pas
pour lui moyen moment
particulièrement de poser un référendum
puisqu'on avait un processus qui était
en cours au Parlement et que quelque
chose qui demande lui qui avait été lui
il aurait pu faire ça c'était dans des
choses qu'on avait effectivement proposé
je crois en 2007 qu'en France avait été
candidat mais il a acté la procédure
telle qu'elle a été décidée et vous
voulez dire que c'est pas un frondeur
François baillon non pas du tout alors
pour le coup on a il a tellement très
bien expliqué hier d'abord les
fondements de la réforme pourquoi il
fallait une réforme parce que je crois
qu'on ne faut pas se renoncer à l'idée
d'expliquer pourquoi il faudrait fondre
contre les français c'est une réforme
pour les français pour le système de
répartition même si ça nécessite
reconnaissant le un certain nombre
d'efforts personne ne peut dire le
contraire mais il dit à chaque fois
qu'il faut faire en sorte qu'elle soit
faisable qu'elle soit qu'elle puisse
passer à l'Assemblée puis que dans
l'opinion et au Sénat et que dans
l'opinion elle soit comprise donc c'est
ça la volonté de François Baro c'est de
faire en sorte que c'est très fin de
Vienne possible dans les débats
parlementaires et dans l'opinion sur le
fond est-ce que vous êtes d'accord aussi
sur l'usage d'un référendum sur cette
question est-ce que c'est pas une
question trop complexe avec que des cas
particuliers mais pardon c'est
exactement d'ailleurs ce qui a dit
François bayrouillard c'est il y a un
moment où les choses sont parfois
complexes ou finalement d'abord c'est
beaucoup d'éléments d'un texte parce que
quand vous prononcez sur un référendum
vous prononcez sur un texte vous
imaginez j'aime bien que c'est un texte
qui est pas un texte à deux ou trois
articles d'ailleurs le Conseil
constitutionnel autant que je viens
vérifie toujours l'intelligibilité de la
question qui est posée et donc il faut
qu'on nourrisse le débat il y a un
parlement
j'ai été ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement c'est au Parlement l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat il faut respecter
dans leur prérogative de faire le
travail à la fois de d'explicitations
puis aussi d'analyse éventuellement
d'amendement je disais tout à l'heure
vous êtes vice-président du modèle le
modèle il a fait un certain nombre de
propositions concernant cette réforme
des retraites il a proposé la hausse des
cotisations patronales il a proposé de
rallonger d'une demi-heure la durée
hebdomadaire du temps de travail des
Français ces propositions elles ont
toutes été refusées par Isabelle borne
qui a souligné l'ironie avec ironie la
créativité du MoDem vous jouez un jeu en
ce moment non pas du tout un jeu d'abord
c'est des choses trop sérieuses pour que
ce soit un jeu n'est pas illégitime
qu'un groupe politique le modem
Renaissance horizon et les autres
groupes politiques qui siègent à
l'Assemblée nationale puisse poser sur
la table des propositions des idées des
réflexions et qu'on puisse s'en débattre
c'est pas si ça ça n'est pas la
démocratie je ne sais pas ce que c'est à
la fin la question qui va c'est ce sur
quoi on peut avoir des terrains
d'entente ce sur quoi on peut faire
évoluer un texte
il y a ça qui est en question mais ça
n'est pas un jeu est-ce que je prends un
jeu de posture c'est pas un jeu de
posture quand François Bayrou fait ça et
il pense pas 2027 on sait on sait qu'il
en rêve différents
je suis vice-président du MoDem je sais
différencier ce que ce sont des
propositions d'un mot qui ont leur
propre autonomie d'ailleurs on le voit
dans tous les groupes est-ce que pense
la formation politique François Bayrou
il a évoqué un certain nombre de piste
le groupe a évoqué un certain nombre de
pistes pardon 2027 nous sommes en
janvier 2023 vous voyez bien ce qui
s'est passé entre 2017 et 2022 je pense
qu'il faut être prudent et François
bayrouler tout autant que moi
il s'en cachent à peine
laissez-les portes ouvertes ça n'est pas
dire qu'on y va laisser les portes
ouvertes c'est la vie politique parce
que si qui sait ce que sera 2027
personne et donc laisser les portes
ouvertes c'est la chose la plus
naturelle qui soit en politique un mot
encore est-ce que Franck Riester
n'a-t-il pas tout simplement dit la
vérité en affirmant que les femmes
seront un peu pénalisées par la réforme
des retraites François Bayrou affirme
lui-même que leur situation mérite
d'être précisé et améliorer il y a donc
un sujet sur les femmes non il y a un
sujet global de l'équilibre de la
réforme on sait très bien que les femmes
sont celles qui ont souvent la carrière
les guerrières les plus hachées avec des
retraites qui sont souvent les plus
faibles donc la referme elle vient
plutôt de ce point de vue là améliorer
les choses par nous le dire aussi des
points d'amélioration après il y a un
logement durée de cotisation de de durée
de côté sur accélération de durée de
cotisation évidemment ça concerne tout
le monde femme et homme donc moi je
crois qu'on a une réforme qui est
équilibrée ça n'empêche pas comme la
très bien dit François Bayrou comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs la première liste
peut-être de préciser les choses là où
il y a des doutes qui peuvent s'exprimer
et puis de regarder
qui ont travaillé et qui ont eu des
enfants c'est elle qui sont le plus
pénalisés et certaines catégories en
plus d'entre elles parce que celles qui
ont qui ont de très bas de très basses
tensions de retraite ce serait plutôt
favorisé dans le dispositif donc ce
qu'il faut regarder ne tirons pas de
d'exemple ou de catégories des
généralités complètes dans le secteur
agricole par exemple il y a un certain
nombre de femmes qui seront plutôt
avantagés par le système tel qu'il va
être qui va être présenté donc il faut
qui est trouvé à chaque fois ce que
peuvent être des trous dans la raquette
si vous permettez l'expression des
jaunes de flou qui doivent être
améliorés et ça c'est le travail
parlementaire qu'il fera justement les
agriculteurs ils prennent en moyenne
leur retraite à
63,4 ans aussi ils vont devoir
travailler forcément plus longtemps
est-ce que c'est pas un peu injuste
quand on voit aujourd'hui
les voilà les difficultés d'être un
agriculteur on est dehors c'est un
travail pénible tout à fait vrai c'est
ce qui a d'ailleurs été pris en compte
dans le premier quinquennat du président
Macron ce qu'on a appelé les lois
Chassaignes président chassés le
président du groupe communiste à
l'Assemblée donc c'est une loi qui vient
pas de neuron mais qui a été votée par
la majorité qui vise à améliorer les
pensions à cette 70 à 85 % d'un SMIC
deuxièmement dans cette réforme ce qu'on
va faire parce que effectivement c'est
des carrières qui sont souvent en fin de
parcours dur parce que la pénibilité est
grande un certain nombre de chefs
d'exploitation sont en arrêt maladie ou
sont alors il y a pas l'arrêt maladie en
tant que tu as le même peuvent pas avoir
exercé une activité à plein temps et ça
les pénalise sur la retraite ça va viser
cette réforme à faire en sorte que ceux
qui en fin de carrière ne peuvent pas
travailler et donc le cotise pas et donc
n'ont pas une retraite à taux plein
allez faire rentrer dans le système pour
qu'ils aient le droit à une retraite à
taux plein donc pour bénéficier de la
retraite minimum à 1200 euros il faut
une carrière complète c'est vrai que ça
en exclure
ce matin que même si on n'a pas une
carrière complète un agriculteur il
pourra obtenir la retraite minimum ils
ont une carrière qu'on prenne de chef
d'exploitation mais pas en activité pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux parce
qu'ils sont ils sont en arrêt maladie
donc oui dans cette configuration là
c'est plus de 50 000 agriculteurs qui
sont aujourd'hui à la retraite qui n'ont
pas pu à la fin de leur carrière
travailler sur leur exploitation et qui
sont pourtant chef d'exploitation et qui
pourront bénéficier la mesure
un mot sur l'Ukraine l'Allemagne les
États-Unis vont bientôt livrer des chars
à l'Ukraine il y avait pourtant des
réticences jusque là est-ce que la
France elle doit elle aussi livrer des
chars Leclerc c'est une réflexion qui
est en cours vous le savez très bien
d'abord la France a beaucoup livré de
matériel je pense au canon César du
matériel
blindé léger qui aussi un élément
important dans la tactique de les
Ukrainiens ont sur le sur leur sol la
question se posera éventuellement pour
les chars Leclerc mais ça dépend aussi
de la disponibilité de la taxe
c'est une question non c'est pas que les
voisins c'est que globalement le nombre
de Charlie ou pas et beaucoup plus
nombreux que le nom
c'est ça il me semble
enfin sur différents
la question qui était d'ailleurs posée
aux Allemands je le rappelle c'était de
savoir s'ils autorisaient à ce que
d'autres livres les Polonais donc cette
question peut se poser et c'est une
question tactique est toujours tactique
mais est-ce que livrer du matériel
sophistiqué comme celui-là ça veut dire
forcément livrer des hommes qui vont
avec pour la formation pour savoir
comment ça fonctionne est-ce que la
Russie elle peut accuser ceux qui vivent
des chars de cobellisé en France
autrement dit est-ce qu'on peut se
retrouver impliquer dans un conflit par
le biais de ces livraisons de chars quel
que soit les armes il y a évidemment de
la formation pour les utilisateurs
comme c'est plus compliqué par ici là
la formation est plus longue et plus
compliquée que c'est pas de la formation
donc on est bien sur le même statut que
toute personne qui livre des armes qui
est celui de la formation à ceux qui
vont être appelés à les utiliser donc
difficulté particulière sur le
territoire ce n'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne vous livrez des armes vous
faites de la formation et c'est pas une
question de cobelligence on voit bien
que les Russes veulent absolument
entraîner dans cette logique pour
justifier de leur propre par ailleurs
mais c'est pas un risque il faut prendre
ces responsabilités quand on est dans
une situation comme celle-là on a besoin
quand même de faire respecter l'état
droit et malheureusement en l'occurrence
l'état droit ne peut être respecté que
en fournissant aux Ukrainiens les moyens
de se défendre
merci